Big new releases seem few and far between
these days, but there’s still plenty to
play, especially if you’ve got Xbox Game
Pass.
Here are 8 games to check out if you’re
subscribed to Microsoft's service.
Life is Strange: True Colors, the latest in
the choice-driven episodic adventure series
from Square Enix is finally on Game Pass.
You play as Alex Chen, who moves to the sleepy
town of Haven Springs to start a new life,
only to be beset with tragedy when she gets
there.
With the help of her newfound friends Steph
and Ryan, she’s determined to figure out
what’s really going on in Haven Springs.
Helping in this quest is her power: Empathy.
Alex can sense and even manipulate the strong
feelings of others, and in True Colors, she
uses it to help the townsfolk of Haven Springs
in many memorable and beautiful ways; from
a woman struggling with keeping a secret from
her granddaughter, to an unlucky kid with
an overactive imagination.
Just like previous Life is Strange games,
True Colors offers a fantastic indie soundtrack
including the likes of Radiohead, Phoebe Bridgers,
and mxmtoon, but beware if you’re streaming
it because… well, let’s just say streamer
mode really takes the mood out of the moment.
But don’t let that discourage you, Life
is Strange: True Colors is a truly heartfelt
and emotional rollercoaster, and as all episodes
come in one package, you’ll probably find
yourself playing all 5 in rapid succession
to get to the bottom of the mystery that lies
at its heart.
Bugsnax is a delightfully bizarre puzzle adventure
game from the team behind Octodad: Dadliest
Catch.
Originally a timed PlayStation exclusive,
the game is finally making its way to other
platforms, and is creeping onto Xbox Game
Pass.
You play as an investigative journalist invited
to the mysterious Snaktooth Island by intrepid
explorer Elizabert Megafig… but when you
arrive, you find she’s gone missing under
suspicious circumstances.
Even weirder are the island’s local fauna,
the eponymous Bugsnax.
Half animal, half… delicious snack, it’s
up to you to scour the land, uncover all the
species, and capture the creatures to solve
the mysteries of Snaktooth Island.
Bugsnax is as adorable as it is zany, and
definitely one that will scratch the Gotta
Catch ‘Em All itch of Pokemon fans.
It does get a little dark as you need to catch
the cutesy Bugsnax and then, er, feed them
to the residents of Snaktooth Isle, but with
a theme song this catchy from Kero Kero Bonito,
who could say no.
Young Horses also recently launched a free
expansion for Bugsnax owners called The Isle
Of Bigsnax, where the Bugsnax are…
well, I’m sure you can guess.
Are you in the mood for a cozy single player
adventure game about an adorable turnip…
who commits CRIMES?
Well, if that very specific mood strikes you,
Turnip Boy Commits Tax Evasion is just the
game for you.
It launched on Steam in 2021 to thousands
of Very Positive user reviews, and now this
cute menace, I mean seriously, look at their
little face, is making their way to Game Pass.
You start the game by being evicted from your
home for failing to pay your taxes.
Burdened with debt and under the thumb of
Mayor Onion, you head out into the world to
pay back what you owe.
Along the way, you solve puzzles, traverse
dungeons, defeat enemies, solve problems for
others, hunt for treasure, and of course,
rip up tax documents to erase your paper trail.
See, not all is as it seems, and there’s
a corrupt government and capitalist pigs to
take down.
The ending of the game depends on just how
good you are at committing and getting away
with tax evasion, so keep that in mind as
you play.
Oh, and did I mention there are hats to collect
and wear?
Very important.
Okay, so far these selections have been very
wholesome…
sort of… so let’s completely 180 that
with 7 Days To Die.
This zombie title is a true mix of gameplay
genres, part first-person shooter, part tower
defense, part RPG, and part survival horror.
Developer The Fun Pimps launched 7 Days to
Die back in 2013 via Steam Early Access, and
now it’s making its way to Xbox Game Pass.
Following a nuclear war that destroyed much
of the world and left it overrun by zombies,
it’s up to you to explore and survive.
Either working cooperatively or alone, you
can build bases, raid settlements, farm, hunt,
craft, loot, drive, kill zombies [intake of
breath].
Yeah, there’s a lot to get to grips with,
but don’t be discouraged, there are years
of fan wikis and a dedicated community ready
to guide you through.
Wanna solve crimes from the safety of your
living room?
Try out Chinatown Detective Agency, a point
and click adventure game with a twist.
You play as Amira Darma, an ex-INTERPOL cop
who has set up her own private detective agency.
As Amira you get to travel around the futuristic,
neon-infused world to meet clients and solve
their cases, but it’s not as simple as just
solving crimes: you’ve got to make sure
your agency remains in the black and budget
for things like expansion and hiring staff.
When it comes to doing actual detective work,
Chinatown Detective Agency requires you to
do your own research, so yes, that can mean
firing up Google to search for answers, or
asking the in-game librarian Mei for help.
If a gritty noir detective game sounds up
your street, then this is the one for you.
If you have Game Pass Ultimate or EA Play,
then here’s a couple that you should take
a look at, first up is Lost in Random, which
is described by publisher EA as “a gothic-fairy-tale-inspired
action-adventure where every citizen's fate
is determined by the roll of a dice”.
I can’t really summarize it more succinctly
than that, so there you have it.
If you’re interested in the premise, the
game was written by Ryan North, who you might
recognise as the author of the Unbeatable
Squirrel Girl.
Playing as a girl named Even and joined by
her dice pal Dicey, your quest is to save
your sister, but the odds are stacked against
you: in the Kingdom of Random, a wicked Queen
with a cursed black dice runs the show.
The gameplay is a mix of card collecting and
tactical combat, all set in gorgeous and twisted
board games, where the world definitely has
a touch of the Tim Burtons about it.
Another one for EA Play and Game Pass Ultimate
subscribers, but Dragon Age 2 has finally
made it to Game Pass.
I know what you’re going to say: there’s
a lot wrong with Dragon Age 2.
Yes, it uses the same environments way, way
too many times, yes it was clearly made in
a bit of a rush and lost a lot of the deep
RPG-ness of Dragon Age Origins, but… is
it still a fun romp?
Yes.
Is it less clunky and more action packed than
the first game?
Also yes.
If like me, you’re twiddling your thumbs
waiting for the next Dragon Age, instead of
replaying Inquisition again–look, we’ve
all been there–why not give Dragon Age 2
another chance.
Okay, secretly I'm not even sure when this
one got put on Game Pass, but Kurt’s not
here to tell me no, so we’re gonna round
off this episode by recommending Alan Wake’s
American Nightmare.
This standalone spin-off to 2010’s Alan
Wake follows our beleaguered best-selling
author as he comes up against his biggest
foe yet: himself.
Or rather, the purely evil version of himself
known as Mr Scratch.
American Nightmare definitely leans more into
more pulpy horror tropes than the original
did, and even added a new arcade mode, essentially
a horde mode where players can battle for
the top spot on leaderboards after they face
waves of enemies.
Since Alan Wake 2's development has finally
been confirmed by Remedy, now really is the
time to go back and play his first couple
of adventures, and if you’ve got the time,
definitely hit up the AWE expansion for Control
to get the full story.
So there you have it, the best games to play
on Xbox Game Pass this month, make sure to
let me know your favorites in the comments
below, and let me know how you get on with
what I’ve recommended.
I’m on Twitter @lucyjamesgames, see ya next
time.